doctors say American kids spending way
too much time on everything from YouTube
to Instagram to fortnight according to
the American Academy of Pediatrics
technology overuse by children is linked
to obesity depression and lower school
performance the June issue of Wired
magazine offers parents a food pyramid
for a healthy tech diet we could all use
that no break we're going right to you
why Nick Thompson come back if you
walked away I was wondering Tony are we
going to break come back if you're in
the other room here we talking we got
Nick Thompson here all right this is a
great idea although I have to point out
that the food pyramid telling us what to
limit and what what to eat a lot of I
don't know that was so successful what
you put we're right so the idea is that
there's some forms of screen use that
are super helpful you should have all
the time right you want to have a video
chat with Grandma yeah that's really
great you want to learn how to code
that's really great and there's some
that's really awful yeah it's real avoid
what are the things that you sparingly
the junk food of screen time never look
at a screen before bed you do not want
your kid getting all riled up before
they go to sleep because they need to
sleep to get healthy and feel good and
you don't want them riled up you don't
want a TV on in the background because
it makes people talk a little bit less
you don't in the background with your
kid you don't want a kid having a screen
at a meal because then they're talking
less to the parents they're interacting
less and they're learning less so that's
the top that kids growth actually that's
the key thing there yep makes growth in
all sorts of ways there's other
complicated stuff right social media is
complicated you kind of want to keep
kids away from that because it can lead
to a lot of social anomie but actually
it can help them engage first-person
shooters I was - yeah I was very
surprised at your take on shooting games
right so that's at the top in moderation
it's in the bad part of the pyramid but
it's not in the band part of the pyramid
so the studies show the playing
first-person shooter video games doesn't
make kids more aggressive when they get
older that's so counterintuitive what we
see and what we hear and if I was also
it they can be more isolated but how is
that so yeah it goes against every
belief I would have I wouldn't want my
kids to play them but it seems like
they're able to separate
the isolation point is interesting
because because it is if you're not
playing video games you're kind of gonna
get left out on right and that it turns
out seems that maybe have a little more
of effect than any bad thing that could
happen with first-person shooter video
games so if your kids playing them talk
to them look at the settings make sure
they're playing them in the right way
you know parents are engaging with their
kids every one of these activities is
better but don't ban them you know you
know what something that comes up for
parents across the country I see it all
the time I debate it myself my own
household is you go to to eat somewhere
yeah and you have an iPhone you give it
to the kid to watch during the meal you
and your spouse can have you know ten
minutes of normal conversation good
thing or bad thing where does that fall
I kid should be involved in the
conversation I mean look you need to
have a heavy conversation with your
spouse you maybe you do need to like
stick your kid in front of Peppa Pig but
I do think that you want to have the
kids conversing right a lot of problems
with screen time it's on us yeah on the
parents look at your screen instead of
your kid you know and so we maybe the
next dish we'll make a food pyramid for
parents on how to deal with screens and
your children what's the healthy stuff
healthy stuff is you know games like
learning how to learn languages right so
my kids use memorize which it's great
one of my kids loves his Kindle
paperwhite you know it's good about the
Kindle paperwhite there's no Twitter on
it there's nothing besides books it's
just text there's nothing flashing
there's nothing going I love having him
use that video chats as long as you're
over to seems like under two you have a
really hard time with two-dimensional
images but above 18 months or to a video
chat with somebody great form of
conversation do it all the time there's
a note here in the magazine said Sesame
Street viewers got higher grades and
were less likely to be held back yeah oh
that's good stuff reticular Sesame
Street viewers who watch it with their
parents all right if you watch a show
with your kids and talk to them about it
and yeah that's much better than just
yeah swapping them in front of YouTube
you know you could watch CBS and yeah we
would I guess this morning great your
kids that is the very best thing even
though the kids are always ahead of
their parents when it comes to
technology so what are parents supposed
to do to keep out yes this is a great
one so one of the pieces of advice would
give is to change your settings make it
appropriate turn on restricted mode in
YouTube check the search history the
funny thing is when the kids get to
about 10 they'll be able to change it
all
settings and delete the search history
and you won't be able to catch up I
think the best thing yeah if the parents
to just be curious and to be curious
about what their kids are doing and to
try to understand it and not to say oh
they're on that internet thing I don't
understand it I'll let them just do it
I'd understand it as best you can
talk to them about what they're doing
and it'll be better for everybody Nick
thank you very much the June issue of
wire this is that magazine thing for any
of the kids watch it features a special
section and children's technology use
it's on newsstands now newsstands where
you buy these